why can this video Mellie Cooney and
malecon mica karttunen yeah I got this
guy before him let's let's play the
color ok so why am I not able to take it
I don't see head really jack yes I know
he can go night you forward this is like
no development at all I mean to just go
Bishop d3 back or is there something
better like a for now that's good enough
okay let's think about this for a moment
she's going to go see voice especially
to Bishop t20 it looks unattractive but
I have have a much better much better
development i am a i'm going to open up
the position very quickly see for Bishop
b2 I'm going you for next move basically
no matter what okay we can play f5 then
I need to do something else but other
than that I'm going to play you for
really really quickly efore takes nine
to five now let's do that it must be
right that must be right
it's not about the extra point it's
about the lead and development okay
should be too
yeah but I that that's really slow right
okay so taking here it's not a great
idea it just opens up his bishop if I go
look the one you probably would retreat
the bishop huh so how are we going to do
that now 1995 taking a 95 it's not very
convincing or is it is it a five should
be to be one bishops III that's not that
bad actually for black ok and spending
far too much time here
far too much
I should just won't play one of the one
of the okay moves instead of going into
the tank all the time rope yourself and
then what he returns I don't know ok I
want to I want to get to get this on the
kingside going ok so he wants to check
and rugby aight i guess yeah let's let's
let's do that i'm going to push stuff
over to the to the three air to the king
sign now Bishop to age 5 or Bishop g4
some attacking a skin
ok so is trying to take it Bishop it
tries to take it takes III that's
actually serious not that's not a move
that I wanted to play really I don't see
what else if you can take here take c3
then even d for false probably it was
really bad to allow the sea for business
yeah in retrospect it really wasn't
wasn't that that terrible for black as
bad as it looked but this does not seem
to be that that bad okay um Bishop g4 or
what is going to is going to go rupee
too probably yeah just a ticking see
tomb
hmm
oh wow not really hard to believe Adam
time morning it's not even a serious
counter player I can well let's let's
fire way here I should have gone to f3
really would have been would have been
much much more promising going there
immediately
alright whatever that's frustrating to
to lose the game after this opening is
really frustrating be five year how came
but what exactly was wrong maybe really
allowing c4 was bad young in this closer
in this closed position the whole thing
wasn't that terrible
I'm just trying to irritate them
probably unsuccessfully there's some way
here to to get anything going uh
probably not don't lay this not even now
there's nothing really can give the
check here on the on the back rank okay
yeah I come when I'm resigning this
nonsense that did i do there i mean i
will be five assists I mean yeah no
words but how do I actually punish him I
mean this this is certainly not so bad
but it is it is not yeah maybe I should
click it and see fire that's not that
bad that's not that bad from like yeah I
was thinking that this quickie for is
this problem but it is not that terrible
fam now it's really not that bad so
maybe here the computer gives Ruby one
and then says wide winds basically when
I didn't consider the move at all me AJ
and wins queena 3m there is no there is
no development I mean be five this is
frankly just a ridiculous movie what
sound hello came push-up d3 was bad yeah
I mean this doesn't refute the whole
thing this is really not clear and from
this point on i was looking for stuff
that probably isn't there I don't know
we have five he has strong play now on
the queenside after Ruby it it it's just
like that here I'm fishing you that's
it's really weird what is a queen-size
play got dangerous really quickly
yeah yeah here this is just just just
just fishing yeah I would be one is this
is much stronger much stronger really he
really has no no move to be honest
something like that and now yeah I mean
I'm 3 p-3 tempe up it's just weird that
that Bishop b3 wasn't as good i mean
it's area also has see for you something
like that and this is really not that
clear funny enough as weird as it looks
so strange game ok thanks for watching